brian armstrong the ceo of coinbase uh
went on a twitter
tirade i would call it last night a
20-tweet thread uh discussing about
their new product about lending so we
have the thread here that we're gonna
pull up and and we'll just read through
uh most of it and try to give you guys
the details
so coinbase
this this uh most simple way to put it
is they're they're adding a lending
product where you can use their
securities and take out funds against
them other crypto brokerages have this
product brian armstrong is trying to
implement it for uh coinbase so brian
armstrong reads some really sketchy
behavior coming out of the sec recently
story time love that he started it was
story time
then he says millions of crypto holders
have been hearing have been earning
yields on their assets over the last few
years it makes sense if you want to lend
out your funds you can earn a return
everyone seems happy a bunch of great
companies in crypto have been offering
versions of this for years coinbase came
out recently and said we would be
launching our own version
then he proceeded to say
they responded by telling us this lend
feature as a security okay that seems
strange how can lending be a security so
we ask the sec to help us understand and
share their view we always make an
effort to work with work proactively
with regulators and keep an open mind
they refuse to tell us why they think
it's a security and instead of sub and
instead they subpoenaed us with a bunch
of records from us we complied demand
testimony from our employees we comply
and then they tell us they will be suing
us if we proceed to launch with zero
explanation as to why
look we're committed to following the
law sometimes the law is unclear so if
the sec wants to publish guidance we're
also happy to follow that it's nice if
you actually enforce it evenly across
the industry a little chirp there from
brian but in this case they're refusing
to offer any opinion in writing to the
industry on what should be allowed and
why and instead are engaging in
intimidation tactics behind closed doors
whatever their theory is it feels like a
reach land grab versus other regulators
meanwhile plenty of other crypto
companies continue to offer a lend
feature but coinbase is somehow not
allowed
so
brian continues and he goes on a bunch
of uh he adds another 10 tweets or so
but the gist of it is he's confused as
to why the sec
is now regulating against coinbase that
they cannot do this other companies
right i think one thing to make
important is clear and like i think john
and paulina feel the same way we don't
know all the details right so we don't
want to get in the nuance of why this is
or is not allowed what the sec's
viewpoint on this is but the facts are
the facts and they're trying to launch
this feature other companies have this
feature live currently and the sec is
saying no so john let's start with you
what do you think about this is is
brian's approach the right way to go
through uh twitter and the traditional
uh versus the traditional pr method it
seems almost uh and i don't want to say
this word but it seems almost like a
desperate approach like he's tried every
other avenue he doesn't know kind of
what else to do he's basically saying
hey look these rules should be industry
agnostic like if you're going to have a
rule have for the entire industry which
i understand you don't want to be
egregious with those rules but look he's
he's taken to twitter and we see there's
more and more people using their
audiences to kind of make a difference
in what's happening in their business
their company um their lives pretty much
so it's interesting to see his approach
um i don't think the sec is gonna
be on twitter and respond to him that
way um but we'll see i mean
i think we're gonna we're gonna get an
answer from the sec pretty shortly if
people start kind of rioting almost yeah
pauline what do you think yeah so uh i
think as a ceo of this company this is
the right approach i like that he said
look we're committed to following the
law sometimes the law is unclear so if
the sec wants to publish guidance we're
also happy to follow that it's nice if
you actually enforce it evenly across
the industry by the way
which is a little bit of a dig but i
think i think it's smart because it's
like
he's he's openly saying like as the ceo
of this massive company we want to
follow the rules just tell us what the
rules are it just reminds me of like
when you know you go to pay your taxes
and you're like trying to guess you know
just tell me what to pay and i'll pay
you why do i have to guess it's the same
thing yeah so i think about this in two
ways i think that uh it's probably a
little bit worse than they made it seem
because they're allowing him to go out
on twitter right and they're releasing
the stuff so i almost he's playing it
all of his in like you know we they got
a subpoena now and it's been going on
for a little bit but it almost makes it
seem like it's much worse than they led
on to believe because he's like i feel
like if you're a pr person like letting
your ceo tweet out to the public about
kind of your fight with the sec is the
last case scenario so that's what they
did they want to be open that's awesome
i'm a fan of that then secondly for the
from the sec perspective uh mark cuban
had a good comment underneath and he
even he essentially said like brian
they're they don't know what to do they
don't know how to regulate this other
companies are doing it they don't want
to be put into a position where they
make the wrong decision so what they're
going to do is they're going to do this
through litigation they're going to
allow the lawyers to get involved and
they're going to let them make the
decision and cuban obviously admitted
that that is probably the worst thing
you want to happen but i thought it was
interesting uh that that's what it seems
right like it seems like the sec doesn't
want to be put in the position to have
to say yes or no on this arrangement
they've obviously let other companies do
it that haven't come to them and say
that we're doing it but at the end of
the day you have to establish framework
that is equal across the industry you
can't allow one player to capitalize on
something the other person isn't so
kudos to coinbase if they actually did
go ahead and go to uh yeah there's mark
cuban's comment right there he said
brian this is regulation versus
litigation they aren't capable of
working through this themselves and are
afraid of making mistakes and doing so
that they leave it to the lawyers just
the people you don't want impacting new
technologies you have to go on the
offensive and i think he's absolutely
right mark mark gets uh some stuff some
crap in the crypto community sometimes
for some of the things he said in the
past and vice versa but in this case i
think he's right in the aspect of like
you have to establish regulations that
are even across competitors with the
industry and you can't allow one
competitor to do something that the
other's not allowed to especially in a
product like lend and lending on
securities that is profitable for these
companies
the problem is is fighting the sec is
tough he says go on the offensive like
what is brian armstrong supposed to do
in that situation well i think he's
saying argue with him right tell him why
that you should be able to do this and
force your way into doing it and to be
determined if that's the right solution
but i think it's interesting that
coinbase is essentially being punished
for going to the sec and saying hey this
is what we're going to do because from
what i can tell other companies that
have implemented this policy and these
guidelines and these uh these products
the lending products have just done it
on their own and say we're launching
these products we're doing these things
and some companies have gotten in
trouble for them and some have kind of
gone freely with them so i think it's
interesting that the sec is taking an
approach of saying hey you came to us
first uh we don't really know what to do
with this so we're gonna involve lawyers
and we're gonna subpoena you and we're
gonna do all these things but we're also
gonna let the same players that didn't
come to us and didn't tell us beforehand
we're gonna allow them to kind of
continue doing business as they are
currently he said he hit up the sec and
said hey look we just give you a heads
up we're launching it we didn't have to
yeah so do you think that he went with
this like approach publicly on twitter
to
tell his customers or do you think he
did it to put pressure on the sec to
give out guidance
yeah i think uh i think it's almost a
ladder and i'm assuming that's what you
think yeah yeah i i think uh it's
interesting because
i
i agreed that uh he wanted to be
proactive but if he wanted to just push
it through he would have done it like
every other company has done coinbase is
one of the largest players in the entire
uh space they're public companies they
they follow kind of different regulatory
rules and they have uh different options
available there uh in their toolkit but
i think at the end of the day what he
wants is he wants framework established
across the entire industry right and he
wants everyone to play by the same rules
he understands that they're a massive
company they have a huge at first mover
advantage uh within the [ __ ]
brokerage uh industry and he wants them
all to follow the same guidelines and by
doing this you almost force the sec's
hand of saying hey look this is the
guidelines we're going to follow if he
has to be the guinea pig in that
situation i'm sure he doesn't love that
but at the end of the day that might get
rules across i'm curious what your guy's
approach is uh on doing it as through
twitter versus traditional pr method
methods
do you like that he's open and he's
doing threads
as a former reporter
i think i think it makes much more sense
for him to do it over twitter there's a
lot of crypto people on twitter paying
attention
i don't think it would have necessarily
maybe gotten the same kind of attention
if it was done through pr in traditional
press but obviously now i am sure that
media companies are gonna pick up his
thread and turn it into an article and
turn into it it also makes it kind of
like journalism is very like one-sided
right like as i'm sure you probably know
a little bit
but you can you write an article right
and it's very hard for people to kind of
debate on the article it's not really
like a forum necessarily and social
media creates that aspect for people to
be able to have the conversation with it
he's got mark cuban responding to his
tweet like it's it's very difficult to
have that kind of level of transparency
between two people um on a traditional
legacy platform yeah i think social
media like this is the thing we always
talk about has changed industries in a
variety of ways right so with athletes
they have the ability to talk to fans
directly the media doesn't play as much
of a role ceos have that same ability
when it comes to regulations and rules
and things that are happening within
their company it's a public company
right there's tons of retail
shareholders that own coinbase and vice
versa people that use the platform and
so on so i think it's cool that brian's
able to do this and he's able to go put
out his opinion and he stayed pretty
fair right he didn't say anything that
was ridiculous he didn't go out of line
and he was pretty open and honest with
their approach to everything so i think
this now throws the ball back in the
sec's court and it's like hey how are
you going to respond to this right and
if they do the same approach of of legal
and litigation and all these things that
people are commenting on i think it's
gonna be a losing approach in the end
because at the end of the day like their
jobs are to set these rules and
regulations and just because crypto is a
new industry that people aren't familiar
with you still have to take it just like
anything else right you have to be able
to understand it you have to look at the
technology and you have to go out and
make rules and regulations against it so
i think brian is uh rightfully probably
a little upset he's trying to move
forward and continue to build his
business and provide services uh and
ultimately please shareholders right and
say look we're offering these new
products we're increasing our revenue
we're pleasing customers were doing all
these things so he's probably a little
frustrated that uh the sec is taking
this much of a of a step back approach
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're gonna be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com
to get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]